1 liste de défense de la ruralité est en préparation
pour les élections
européennes de juin deux-mille-vingt-quatre.
Elle pourrait être conduite par Willy shren,
le président de la fédération nationale des chasseurs,
motivé par le succès du mouvement
agriculteur citoyen aux Pays-Bas.
La liste adopterait 1 ton eurosceptique
avec 1 critique de la technocratie
bruxelloise et des contraintes
environnementales.
Elle ne serait pas uniquement composée de chasseurs
puisqu'on y retrouverait également des agriculteurs,
des viticulteurs, des pêcheurs,
des maires de petites communes
ou encore des défenseurs des traditions locales
comme la Toro Machi.
Parmi les candidats,
il pourrait y
avoir l'ancien député macroniste Jean-Baptiste Moreau,
qui est agriculteur de profession,
ou l'orange-aout,
le maire de saint-brest dans l'Hérault,
1 défenseur des traditions torines.
Derrière cette opération,
on retrouve le lobbyiste de la chasse tyricoste,
1 proche du président,
au point que certains estiment que
cette liste a pour seul objectif de prendre des poids
au RN et favoriser la majorité
en privé. Willy shren a
su pouvoir obtenir des élus européens sans souci,
autrement dit dépasser les 5%,
ce qui n'est pas arrivé depuis
mille-neuf-cent-quatre-vingt-dix-neuf
pour 1 liste de défense de la ruralité.
Cette année-là,
Jean saint-jos
avait récolté près de 7% des suffrages
pour le mouvement chasse,
pêche, nature et tradition,
permettant ainsi l'élection de 6 députés européens.